hey guys also good though I am
absolutely obsessed with emojis and if
you're like me most of your text
conversations probably include at least
one of them or two or three or four or
five because you can basically say
whatever you want but I've recently been
getting a little bored of the
standard-issue iPhone emojis so I've
started creating my own using my real
face but the best part is I will not
only take a picture but sometimes I will
make a little movie accompanying a sound
effect that I think that emoji would
make are you following I am going to go
through and I'm going to give you guys
an example of what I text people and the
noises that I think that these emojis
would make
and that my friends is what I think that
the emojis actually would sound like if
they were real and they had emotions
that's what they would be if you liked
this video please like and favorite it
share with your friends who also maybe
emoji obsessed and don't forget to
subscribe and I will see you guys here
another day when I post another video